liebe kolleginnen liebe kollegen
herzlich willkommen in der
bundespressekonferenz zu unserem schon
traditionellen pressekonferenz marathon
nach wahlen und dazu begrüße ich ganz
ganz herzlich als erstes die linkspartei
ist am platz genommen susanne henning
welt so zu meiner rechten sie ist die
bundesvorsitzende der partei die linke
daneben platz genommen dietmar bartsch
und janine wissler sie waren die
spitzenkandidaten bei der
zurückliegenden bundestagswahl
bevor wir zu den statements an den
fragen kommen da diese pressekonferenz
live übertragen wird noch mal der
hinweis die bundespressekonferenz
ist keine institution der
bundesregierung sondern ein unabhängiger
verein von journalistinnen und
journalisten die aus berlin oder die
bundespolitik berichten unsere aufgabe
ist dass pressekonferenzen zu
veranstalten damit unsere mitgliedschaft
umfassend informiert wird
dann vor allem weisen sie haben das wort
wetter schön
ja schon morgen auch von unserer seite
können sich vorstellen dass wir eine
lange nacht hatten und der morgen früh
begonnen hat aber das nur am rande die
partei die linke hat wirklich einen
herben schlag mit diesem wahlergebnis am
vergangenen abend
bekommen wir haben
schwer verloren und wir wissen dass wir
eine schwere niederlage eingefahren
haben und das können sie sich vorstellen
dass das für uns natürlich auch das
letzte blaue auge ist was wir uns
abgeholt haben weil wir das auch 1
tatsächlich letzte chance verstehen
tatsächlich unsere partei auf nach vorne
zu entwickeln
das ergebnis ist aber nicht nur für die
parteien die linke bitter sondern es vor
allem für diejenigen bieter die
millionen die
dringend eine sozialpolitische
interessenvertretung in der
bundesregierung brauchen und im
bundesparlament brauchen insofern
ist der wahlkampf und die ersten runden
am wahlabend auch derjenigen die jetzt
eine koalition bilden wollen sei es
schon bei karsais die ampel durchaus
erkenntnisreich dass das thema der
sozialen frage was armut angeht was
niedriglöhne angeht was gesunde
ernährung angeht hat vier
wohnverhältnisse
definitiv in der nächsten koalition kaum
eine rolle spielen wird und
dass natürlich auch
für uns im nächsten deutschen bundestag
in denen wir jetzt als fraktionen
einziehen werden mit 39 abgeordneten
weiterhin das thema sein mit dem wir uns
widmen das zweite
natürlich gibt es keine ein punkt
erklärung für das ergebnis der partei
die linke in diesem wahlkampf
die erklärung der ursachen ist nicht
ganz einfach und ist sehr komplex und
auch über viele jahre aufgebaut und
nicht erst in den letzten wochen
entstanden insofern haben sie bitte
verständnis dafür dass wir heute nicht
braucht gefühle und emotionen
entscheiden lassen und über ursachen
reden sondern wir werden als
parteivorstand als parteien der
gesamtpartei mit der fraktion natürlich
intensiver auseinandersetzung gehen wo
die ursachen findet dieses wahlergebnis
liegt
beziehungsweise natürlich den weg hinaus
finden und unsere partei aus meiner
sicht auf neu erfinden
wahlkampf um es mal deutlich zu sagen
war durch den linke stark mit der
sozialen frage verknüpft wir haben damit
nicht verfangen können am ende war es
die rote socken kampagne die
konzentrations debatte die uns wieder
aufmerksamkeit gebracht hat nicht
ausreichend genug
offenbar und der mal am zeigt uns ja
auch dass die polarisierung in den
letzten 48 stunden dazu geführt hat dass
die parteien die linke in der frage wer
soll kanzler werden scholz oder laschet
als kleine partei zerrieben worden ist
die vena abgänge richtung spd und grüne
sprechen da ein deutliches wort wir
haben da an dem punkt nicht überzeugen
können dass wir teil einer veränderung
sein können und ernsthafter weise ist
auch keine veränderung in diesem land
gewählt wurden mit diesem ergebnis aber
ich will ja nicht zu viel vorwegnehmen
und wurde jetzt das
ist ja vielen dank der dieses
wahlergebnis ist ein schwerer schlag für
die partei die linke
und natürlich das bundesweiten
durchschnitt aber auch wenn man sich das
genauer betrachtet dann kann man
wirklich feststellen dass der
flächendeckend verluste haben wirklich
schmerzliche verluste und das auf jeden
fall ein tiefer einschnitt ist man kann
wir sind natürlich froh und dankbar über
die drei direktmandate aus berlin und
leipzig gesine lötzsch gregor gysi und
sören kämen die den wir zu verdanken
haben dass wir jetzt auch wieder in
fraktionsstärke in den bundestag
einziehen und natürlich auch der dank an
alle anderen wahlkämpferin und
wahlkämpfer die sich in den letzten
wochen da so eingebracht haben und in
einer schwierigen situation da wirklich
gekämpft haben ja ich denke auch es muss
jetzt wirklich darum gehen die fehler zu
analysieren
mein eindruck ist dass die probleme eben
nicht oder die fehler nicht in den
letzten zwei monaten in dieser heißen
wahlkampfphase entstanden sind sondern
deutlich tiefer liegen und auch über
längere zeit entstanden sind weil sicher
ist es so dass wir jetzt auf den
allerletzten metern vermutlich noch
einmal einem prozent nachgegeben haben
weil das halt einfach dieses kopf an
kopf rennen zwischen holz und laschet
gegeben hat aber das wäre nicht kein
problem die kein so großes problem
gewesen wenn wir eben weil acht neun
oder zehn prozent gestanden hätten oder
standen wir halt einfach nicht also wir
sind halt in diesem wahlkampf schon rein
mit 67 prozent umfragen und das ist halt
einfach zu wenig und deswegen müssen wir
schauen wo sind die probleme und auch
paar wahlen jetzt in der vergangenheit
haben wir schon gezeigt in den ländern
in denen die kommunalwahlen dass wir das
schwierigkeit gibt ja jetzt muss es
darum gehen die vier jahre zu nutzen
und die partei neu aufzustellen
also die strukturellen probleme
anzugehen und auch an der
außendarstellung zu arbeiten die linke
muss deutlich machen wir sind die partei
der sozialen gerechtigkeit die partei
der mieterinnen und mieter wir wollen
konsequenten klimaschutz voranbringen
und ich glaube da müssen wir dass die
gründe warum es diese partei gibt und
die wir nach vorn stellen wollen die
auch wirklich deutlicher machen in der
öffentlichkeit ja es ist so dass wir für
die regierungsbildung jetzt keine rolle
spielen was die mehrheitsverhältnisse
angeht das heißt der nächsten
bundesregierung werden wieder entweder
die union oder die fdp oder
möglicherweise sogar beide angehören wir
glauben dass das für dieses thema
soziale gerechtigkeit auch beim thema
klimaschutz ein großes problem ist und
vieles blockieren und bremsen wird aber
wir werden jetzt die
sondierungsgespräche beziehungsweise
koalitionsverhandlungen natürlich
beobachten aber sind nicht selber davon
ja auch von mir nen schönen und habe
meine damen und herren ich habe mich dem
nur anschließen dass das gestern für uns
eine schwere wahlniederlage war
natürlich gibt es externe faktoren die
für uns ungünstig waren aber
die können wir ja nur begrenzt
beeinflussen ich will ausdrücklich den
dank unterstützen an die gewinner der
drei direktmandate gesine lötzsch an
gregor gysi und an syrien hellmann da
kann man nur den hut ziehen und sie
waren in dem fall unsere versicherung
dass wir in den deutschen bundestag auch
in fraktionsstärke wieder einziehen
werden ich teile die sich das nicht der
wahlkampf die ursache gelegt hat sondern
dass diese ursachen grundsätzlicher
natur sind und in den letzten jahren
gelegt worden sind und da müssen wir
schlussfolgerung ziehen die tatsache
dass sozialdemokraten und grünen bei
dieser wahl elf prozent zugelegt haben
und wir verloren haben muss uns
nachdenklich stimmen und ich glaube dass
heute niemand abschließend sagen kann
das sind die einzelnen ursachen das wird
in der zukunft zu geschehen haben wir
müssen einige grund fragen stellen und
wir müssen diese grundfragen auch
beantworten mit sicherheit ein faktor
dass wir in den letzten jahren nicht als
geschlossene formation ausgetreten
aufgetreten sind sondern leider ein bild
der zerrissenheit vielfach abgegeben
haben dass es auch sehr schade dass
zusammen und janine erst sehr spät als
parteivorsitzende gewählt worden sind
aber das ist nicht mehr korrigierbar
eine dritte bemerkung ich kurz machen
will ist das thema ost kompetenz
natürlich stimmt mich das in besonderer
weise traurig dass wir nur noch in drei
ländern des ostens überhaupt zweistellig
sind
da müssen wir da müssen wir dringend die
kompetenz die wir haben auch wieder
sichtbar machen denn wir waren in der
letzten legislaturperiode die partei die
dass dieses thema nicht nur aufgerufen
hat sondern konkrete vorschläge gemacht
hat wenn man sich das substanziell
betrachtet wirklich die ost
interessenvertreterin ist aber das
entscheiden wählerinnen und wähler und
nicht wie er deshalb wird für uns auch
die frage der regierungsbildung in den
beiden ländern die gestern auch gewählt
haben berlin und mecklenburg vorpommern
nicht ganz unerheblich sein
der ausblick kurz und knapp ja wir
werden die oppositionsrolle deutschen
bundestag annehmen wir werden das
soziale gewissen im nächsten deutschen
bundestag sein und es wird darauf
ankommen dass wir gemeinsam und
solidarisch agieren das was wir von der
gesellschaft einfordern muss
selbstverständlich bei uns zuallererst
gelten dankeschön
er hat sich natürlich einige statements
dann kommen wir zu fragen und zwar die
erste hat reitschuster
wels haben sie schon mit sarah wang
nicht telefoniert und laden sie die
künftig noch besser einzubinden danke
ja auch entschuldigung
also ich habe gestern mit sahra
wagenknecht kommuniziert wir haben heute
noch nicht gesprochen sie können sich
vorstellen dass unsere tage gestern
relativ eng getaktet waren und natürlich
werden wir in der morgen
fraktionssitzung an miteinander reden
das war wahnsinnig für spitzenkandidatin
in nordrhein westfalen natürlich haben
wir auch gestern miteinander geredet sie
hat leider auch in nordrhein westfalen
nur 3,1 erzielt aber sie wird in unserer
fraktion sein und wir werden gemeinsam
betone dass sowie im wahlkampf gemeinsam
für die stärkung der linken und für
einen neuen aufbruch kämpfen
ich habe er nichts hinzuzufügen
wer macht morgen wird sich die
fraktionen treffen und dann werden wir
das gemeinsam diskutieren und außerdem
zusatz
haben gesagt die partei muss sich neu
erfinden wie viel sahra wagenknecht wird
in dieser neue erfindung sein nach ihrem
gusto
ich habe ja auch gesagt dass es einen
komplex aus ursachen gibt was keine ein
punkt theorie sein kann warum wir da
stehen wo wir sind das bedeutet auch
dass wir jetzt erst mal jeden stein der
uns als partei die linke politisch
strategisch taktisch kommunikativ
was hier veränderungen angeht was unsere
struktur angeht
umdrehen werden und das bedeutet jetzt
nicht antworten zu haben wie wir
weitermachen sondern dass es wenn wir
sagen wir wollen unsere partei neu
erfinden bedeutet ist dass das bedeutet
nicht dass ich heute um 10 uhr 45
nachdem gestern abend eine antwort
darauf habe
die nächste folge hermle
danke komödie bonner general-anzeiger
freihändig weil wissler müssen sie nach
diesen betriebsunfall jetzt nicht
dringend an den sonderparteitag ihrer
partei angerufen und welche positionen
glauben sie müssen sie auf die reparatur
die jetzt ansteht überarbeiten und
herbert können sie bitte mal zumindest
einigen grund sagen warum sie glauben
dass die linke nicht mehr die ost
kompetenz hat die die wählerinnen
jedenfalls bei ihnen mal gesehen hat
danke
ja ich war anfang mitte frage nach den
sonderparteitag
also wir sind jetzt einen tag nach
diesem wahlergebnis der
parteivorstand wird sich am wochenende
zu einer klausurtagung treffen und da
werden wir alle fragen beraten also auch
die frage wie wir jetzt auch breit in
der mitgliedschaft in der partei zu
einer diskussion kommen zu einer fehler
bewertung zu einer analyse und natürlich
auch das für schlussfolgerungen welche
schluss form beziehen aber da gibt es
jetzt im moment noch keine
entscheidungen darüber
ja und ich denke bei den positionen
naja also was mich sehr nachdenklich
macht ist dass wenn wir an so vielen
zentralen punkten also gerade die wir im
wahlkampf nach vorne gestellt haben doch
eigentlich gesellschaftliche mehrheiten
es gibt also auch dass die frage
vermögenssteuer ist oder oder rente oder
höherer mindestlohn die pflege dann
macht es mich schon nachdenklich dass
wenn es darüber eigentlich mehrheiten
gibt dass das überhaupt nicht dazu führt
dass wir eben eine deutliche also dass
sie nicht deutlich stärker sind sondern
eben jetzt ganz im gegenteil deutlich
verloren haben und das muss uns zu
denken geben und darüber müssen wir da
denke ich meine die schule nachricht von
gestern abend aus unserer sicht ist ja
dass das volksbegehren hier in berlin
deutsche wohnen wo novia deutsche
wohnung zu enteignen hatte eine sehr
sehr sehr deutliche mehrheit getroffen
also das hätte ich nicht gedacht muss
ich ehrlich sagen dass das so klar
ausgeht aber das zeigt ja schon dass
themen die wir im wahlkampf gewählt
haben ja durchaus relevant und wichtig
sind und wir müssen sehr schonungslos
mal analysieren warum wir aber davon ja
einfach überhaupt nicht bei wahlen dann
dazu das dazu führt dass wir stärker
werden wobei in berlin haben das
ergebnis einigermaßen gehalten aber
trotzdem
ich habe jetzt nichts
gesagt lieber meldet so aus kompetenz
kann ich ihnen wirklich in einem satz
nicht sagen also entweder wir haben denn
die bereitschaft eine viertelstunde
zuzuhören das machen wir aber lieber
individuell aber fakt ist dass ich habe
ja nicht gesagt werden die verloren
deutlich gesagt und das könnte ich auch
nachweisen dass wir das in der letzten
legislaturperiode und auch weiter auch
im wahlkampf deutlich gemacht haben ob
das das thema rentenangleichung betrifft
ob es die vertretung ostdeutscher
betrifft aber das hat offensichtlich
nicht so gezielt dass das in der
bundesregierung keine ministerin und
keinen minister auf dem posten gibt dass
es in der justiz in der wirtschaft in
der bildung eine mangelnde repräsentanz
gibt das war für viele nicht
entscheidend und deshalb müssen wir
diese frage auch behandeln fakt ist aber
auch dass wir als partei und fraktion
dieses thema zu wenig auf der agenda
hatten da gibt es viele gründe das hat
natürlich mit der gesamtdeutschen partei
zu tun das war als wir noch pds waren
oder im osten 20 prozent im westen
tapfer um 1 prozent gekämpft haben eine
andere situation
und das ist eine herausforderung das ist
eine herausforderung für uns und
selbstverständlich wir wollen auch in
den neuen wie in den alten ländern auch
in regierungsverantwortung auf
landesebene etwas verändern und damit
verliert man ein stück weit den protest
charakter das ist nun mal leider so und
da haben wir eine aufgabe haben wir eine
aufgabe ansonsten wie gesagt gern
individuell und dann in einem längeren
vortrag
spannendere
die nächste frage herr kollege
das kommt vom deutschlandfunk an das
spitzenduo im politbarometer haben 51
prozent angegeben dass
das
soziale gerechtigkeit für die
persönliche wahlentscheidung
entscheidend ist und sogar 57 prozent
der unions wähler sagen dass der
wohlstand in deutschland ungleich
verteilt ist wie bringen sie das
zusammen mit dem ergebnis dass die linke
jetzt geholt hat
wir haben also dass ich habe ja eben
schon gesagt dass das genau also ich
habe diese zahlen auch gesehen ja und
das ist finde ich genau die frage die
wir beantworten müssen also wenn das
thema soziale gerechtigkeit so eine
entscheidende rolle spielt warum die
partei die linke da mal einer wahl ja in
solch dramatischen dimensionen verliert
und nicht dazugewinnen kann also das ist
exakt die frage ob die mich sehr
umtreibt wie das sein kann weil ich eben
jetzt zumindest den eindruck habe dass
wir wahlkampf nicht auf die falschen
themen gesetzt haben also wenn man jetzt
nicht die nachwahlbefragung anschaut und
die menschen sagen was die themen war
ihnen wichtig waren sie zum beispiel im
sozialen gerechtigkeit die rente
klimaschutz und das sind ja schon die
themen auf die wir auch schwerpunktmäßig
gesetzt haben ich glaube wir müssen uns
da sehr genau überlegen wieso die linke
daneben offensichtlich nicht als die
kraft wahrgenommen wird die das thema
soziale gerechtigkeit
ja also die dass die man wählt wenn er
an das thema soziale gerechtigkeit
am herzen liegt mehr weil ich mein
eigentlich sind das 90 prozent unserer
anträge im bundestag glaube ich gehen um
das thema soziale gerechtigkeit machen
den büros haben wir hartz4 beratungen
also wir sind ja wie bei den streikenden
jetzt auch unterwegs gewesen also aber
ich finde die frage gilt es eben jetzt
auch in der analyse zu beantworten warum
es da so einer diskrepanz gibt
also ich will nur ergänzen dass ich in
den zahlen eine chance für uns sehe ist
uns diesmal offensichtlich nicht
gelungen nicht gelungen bei denjenigen
die das wie sie beschrieben haben so
sehen da auch wählerinnen und wähler zu
pürieren und ein punkt ist mit
sicherheit der das uns nicht wenige die
durchsetzung kompetenz nicht zugetraut
haben da hat letztlich ja das
funktioniert dass die union mit der
roten socken kampagne gesagt hat das
land wird ganz furchtbar dann
in armut und im elend enden das ist ja
das was vor wahlen immer erzählt ich
kann mich da gut noch empfehlen erinnern
also als damals programmen und
ministerpräsident wurde und da wurde
wirklich ja das gespenst ist bald wieder
bananen noch bratwürsten thüringen und
das hat das hat ein stück weit
funktioniert hat die die sagen es nutzt
euch das ist ein irrglaube ist schon so
dass menschen dann gerne auch die haben
wollen in regierungsverantwortung aber
vor allen dingen sehe ich diese zahlen
für uns als herausforderung und auch als
chance
die nächste folge erlitten
ng der tag in der schlussphase des
wahlkampfs schlug die dem atom das
bundeswehrmandat ein und die haltung der
linken zur nato wie
überarbeitungsbedürftig sehen sie
sicherheit sondern außenpolitische
haltung der linken
also das ist ja eine sache die
wesentlich die fraktionen getroffen hat
deswegen will ich da ja bemerkungen zu
machen also gerade bei den mandat in
afghanistan
und das haben wir im wahlkampf erlebt
finde ich dass die anderen parteien ihre
haltung in den letzten 20 jahren mal
überdenken sollten dieses desaster was
dort zu verzeichnen ist das ergebnis von
politik und zwar 2001 beginnt und dann
2021 ändern dass die anderen es
geschafft haben eine reduktion auf eine
abstimmung was die evakuierung betrifft
die dann noch aus meiner sicht wirklich
in form einer denunziatorischen
kommunikation stattgefunden hat das ist
so das sind unsere politischen
wettbewerber das finde ich nicht in
ordnung das finde ich falsch das war
auch sachlich falsch man stimmt einfach
nicht dass gesagt worden ist wir wollten
nicht evakuieren und ähnlich ist aber
in diesem sinne dass wir jetzt sagen das
muss jetzt alles weg und wir müssen so
werden wie die anderen mit sicherheit
nicht aber was immer bleibt und das gilt
für alle felder linke ist und muss
bleiben programmpartei bleiben und da
muss über alle fragen und die
außenpolitische entwicklung wie auch die
innenpolitisch so rasant die
veränderungen sind so rasant und die
herausforderungen so ich sage ihnen
voraus wenn die regierung gebildet ist
in einem halben jahr wird es vielfach
menschen geben die sagen ja das habe ich
aber so gar nicht gewollt sage ich ihnen
voraus war beim letzten mal auch so weil
wenn wir keine weichenstellung vornehmen
in den vier jahren ich habe da eine
gewisse skepsis
ich habe da eine gewisse skepsis dann
kriegen wir große probleme deshalb ist
es so wichtig dass wir natürlich diese
zeit jetzt in der opposition im
deutschen bundestag auch nutzen und da
spielt spielt diese fragen eine rolle
aber ist auf gar keinen fall so dass man
sagen kann das ist jetzt alles falsch so
verändern dass das glaub ich unsinn was
uns ich finde dass afghanistan und im
übrigen auch die situation mali er zeigt
dass wir so ganz falsch und unsere
positionen nicht gelegen haben
die lebens partei bleiben ihren tipps
diese frage
beantwortet sich selbst die alternative
wäre wir wollen kriegspartei werden und
ich sage ihnen das nicht der fall bei
der linken ganz sicher ja im moment ist
es ja auch so dass er auch die anderen
bundeswehr- einsatz sehr wirklich auf
den prüfstand stehen also es hat ja die
verteidigungsministerin sagt alle
bundeswehr einsetzen müssen auf den
prüfstand
die
debatte über mali steht er auch an also
wir haben es ja nicht irgendwie eine
position mal zusammen überlegt sondern
das ist ja wirklich so dass die realität
und das hat afghanistan ja gezeigt 20
jahre bundeswehreinsatz 20 jahre krieg
eben zu welcher situation als dort
geführt hat und jetzt muss man mit den
taliban verhandeln die stärker sind als
vorher weil sie auf einer gut
ausgerüstet haben hier zurückgreifen
können also von daher klar natürlich
bleibt die linke konsequente
friedenspartei und mein eindruck ist
aber wir haben ja eben auch über die
frage gesprochen was wahlentscheidend
war also mein eindruck ist jenseits der
inhaltlichen frage dass die
außenpolitischen fragen nicht
wahlentscheidend waren so ist das also
zumindest in allen befragungen jetzt war
das thema außenpolitik
nicht wahlentscheidend aber klar ist
unsere position kenne war vom export
keine militäreinsätze
das bleibt natürlich weiter unsere
position und er dass wir uns so abrüsten
einsetzen
die nächste frage frau kollegin
sarah frühauf ard-hauptstadtstudio guten
morgen frau wissler herr ramelow hat
schon gesagt dass im wahlkampf auf
falsche team gesetzt worden sei man habe
zum beispiel zu viel über und länder
sternchen gesprochen waren sie im
wahlkampf doch zu sehr lifestyle linke
wie privat nicht das gerne bezeichnet
und erbat die linke hatte an den
vergangenen wochen klargemacht sie will
mitregieren und hat auch einige hat auch
gezeigt dass sie zu kompromissen bereit
ist haben sie darüber hinaus die
opposition vielleicht vergessen
also ich kenne das der zitat jetzt nicht
also ich kann nur sagen ich habe in
keiner einzigen wahlkampfrede über
gender sternchen gesprochen also dass
und wir hatten dazu können la carte wir
hatten einen satz glaube ich in einem
sehr umfangreichen wahlprogramm zum
thema geschlechtersensible sprache also
von daher wusste ich jetzt nicht dass
das in unserem wahlkampf größe eine
rolle gespielt hätte also wir haben
immer deutlich gemacht dass wir die
bestehenden
ungleichheiten die bestehenden
ungerechtigkeiten beseitigen müssen aber
ich glaube dass das thema gender
sternchen jetzt nicht zentral wahrheit
diesem bei kupfer sei zumindest nicht
wahrgenommen also ich bin darauf auch
sehr selten ganz ganz selten mal
angesprochen worden überhaupt auf diese
fragen von daher würde ich jetzt sagen
also es war nicht teil unseres wahlkampf
sondern wie gesagt wir haben ein
programm einsatz dass wir die
geschlechter schritt den dieb oder
generelle sensible sprache wollen aber
wir haben das ja als bei uns dich zum
thema gemacht
ich kann mir gar nicht vorstellen dass
bodo ramelow das gesagt hat weil das ist
quatsch also wir haben überhaupt nicht
über gender sternchen geredet im
wahlkampf und auch nicht als lifestyle
linke agiert ist wirklich quatsch punkt
und dass die frage opposition betrifft
man geht in wahlkämpfe es sei denn man
kommt aus der außerparlamentarischen
sicht natürlich wird dem anspruch auf
regierungsverantwortung zu übernehmen
das ist ja auch nichts besonderes das
dürfte im übrigen für alle länder zu wo
wir in landtags palla in
landesparlamenten sinn und auf der
bundesebene ist das ähnlich das ist auch
nicht neu gewesen auch im letzten
wahlkampf war das schon so dass wir
gesagt haben natürlich sind wir bereit
regierungsverantwortung zu übernehmen
wenn die bedingungen stimmen und klar
ist auch wir sind opposition zu den
gesellschaftlichen verhältnissen dass
wir dieses vielleicht
mehr akzentuieren hätten können oder so
dass witze da werden wir darüber reden
müssen aber ich würde heute diese
schlussfolgerung so nicht ziehen wollen
da werden wir darüber reden dass auch
völlig in ordnung da werden wir
analysieren müssen was denn die ursache
war auch für abwanderung fakt ist dass
es da einfacher antworten nicht die und
ehrlich gesagt wenn ich die antworten
jetzt wissen würde ich hätte sie dann
schon vier wochen vorher meiner partei
verraten habe ich ihnen sicher sagen
aber ich glaube das führt darauf zurück
dass die cdu fraktion im thüringer
landtag der auffassung war dass gender
sternchen zu verbieten sind und deswegen
hat er sich dazu geäußert nicht in
unserem wahlkampf konkret insofern sehr
sandy jeannin sternchen geäußert hätten
als symbol für die gleichstellung von
mann und frau wäre es gerechtfertigt wir
haben aber diese form des wahlkampfes so
nicht geführt wie sie negativ uns
gegenüber jahr
kommentiert wird und deswegen natürlich
ist die gleichstellung von mann und frau
immer ein thema für die partei die linke
und das haben wir tatsächlich getan also
insofern
habe ich dafür tun mit
weniger zugespitzt gefragt natürlich ist
muss die linke sich natürlich jetzt
fragen an welche richtung welche
wählerschaft spricht sie an etwas einmal
die urbane wir haben drei
direktmandate gewonnen im urbanen
regionen oder sind das wie wir gesagt
haben herr bartsch ist es eher der dass
ostdeutschland auf das man sich
fokussieren und konzentrieren muss
kriegt man beides zusammen dass er die
herausforderung von der sie stehen oder
wissen sie wenn ich sage ostdeutsche
interessen wahrnehmen ist es doch nicht
etwa eine zielrichtung dass wir uns auf
ostdeutschland konzentrieren das wäre
auch völlig falsch er war auch kein
zufall dass eine spitzenkandidaten aus
den alten ländern eine aus den neuen
ländern kamen wir sind gesamtdeutsche
partei ohne wenn und aber aber wir haben
eine besondere verantwortung bei der
wahl name aus deutscher interessen und
da müssen wir bis in die kommunalebene
er will wir haben an diesem wochenende
auch zwei spannende wahlen gehabt einmal
in teltow fläming die landratswahl da
sind wir in der stichwahl dass zum
beispiel ziemlich wichtig dass wir das
gewinnen und in druck gehen nicht sind
wir auch eine stichwahl das ziemlich
wichtig dass wir das gewinnen das sind
die punkte wo wir auch deutlich machen
müssen dass ganz konkret wir umsetzen
wie dass wir das ein stück also ich kann
das jetzt von meinem bundesland sagen
verloren haben da ist es eben wir haben
eben den mecklenburg vorpommern keine
landräte keine oberbürgermeister mehr
das hatten wir alles mal und das ist
glaube ich eine herausforderung die für
uns alle steht wird alles steht das ist
ja nicht das fällt ja nicht vom himmel
ist ja nicht wir wollen jetzt mal wieder
ein paar landräte stellen das wollen wir
aber das reicht nicht dann müssen wir
mehr ansetzen aber das ist kein
widerspruch also ost kompetenz heißt
doch nicht dass wir uns auf dem posten
etwa und auch dieser punkt mehr u-bahn
oder eher ländlich liegt muss immer auch
partei der ländlichen regionen seien
ohne wenn und aber und ein wahlkampf der
nur auf die städte fokussiert wäre haben
wir nicht gemacht wir waren auch in
kleineren städten und haben das über
wirklich nicht selbstverständlich also
muss man sagen in der analyse sehen aber
was war es ist
natürlich haben wir in den städten eine
andere verankerung durch
kommunalvertretung durch mitglied
aber gerade deshalb bleibt die
herausforderung die herausforderung
bleibt dürfte sowieso als partei nie
vergessen wo wir herkommen wir sind eine
partei die aus der arbeiter bewegung
entstanden ist das dürfen wir nie
vergessen und deswegen immer auch bei
die interessen derjenigen wahrnehmen ich
sehe diesen widerspruch auch nicht immer
zu den gleichstellungspolitischen fragen
sie ihn nicht also eine linke die das
nicht zusammen denkt ist keine linke ich
finde das ist da
viele punkte gibt die man noch ganz gut
zusammenbringen kann weil ich sag jetzt
mal ob man jetzt ein prekär beschäftigte
fahrradkurier in berlin ist oder eine
verkäuferin die irgendwo im ländlichen
raum lebt beide haben ein hohes
interesse an einer guten rente zum
beispiel also oder
einer guten gesundheitsversorgung ja
dass die pflegekräfte gut ausgeruht sind
und alle haben ein interesse daran dass
es eine vernünftige öpnv verbindung gibt
auch wenn die problemlagen im ländlichen
raum andere sind als in der stadt und
ich denke dass zusammenzubringen und
auch durchaus das ist ja eigentlich die
stärke der was eigentlich die stärke der
linken auch sein könnte diese
verschiedenen milieus zusammenzubringen
und das gemeinsame zu betonen
darum müsste es ja eigentlich gehen also
die durchaus auch menschen
unterschiedlich anzusprechen aber ich
denke dass die interessen in diesem land
ja nicht konträr verlaufen zwischen
urbanen und/oder
urbanen schichten und setzt irgendwie im
ländlichen raum oder so sondern dass man
das eben zusammenbringen kann eben
gerade an solchen fragen wie gesundheit
und rente und
klimaschutz das sind ja dass probleme
die wir flächendeckend haben ich habe
noch eine online frage und zwar hans
jessen fragt wird die linke tatsächlich
als fraktion in den bundestag einziehen
oder nicht doch als gruppe mit
verminderten rechten und er fügt hinzu
ist trotz der grund mandats klausel der
fraktionsstatus nicht an die
abgeordnetenzahl gebunden die fünf
prozent entspricht
also die regeln deutschen bundestages
sehr einfach fünf prozent der
abgeordneten des bundestages bilden eine
fraktion und wir werden mehr als fünf
prozent der abgeordneten haben und
deshalb fraktion sein das ist nicht die
fünf prozent das wird gemeinhin so
geschrieben und gesagt stimmt aber nicht
sondern fünf prozent der ab wenn man die
hat bildet man eine fraktion theoretisch
könnten jetzt auch abgeordnete aller
parteien endlich zusammenfinden wenn
zehn prozent sind können sie eine
fraktion bilden
spannende frage war man in früheren
zeiten abwandernden eine gruppe bilden
kann das war mal eine interessante frage
aber es stellt sich schon sonnig denn
die nächste frage herr klinge
jana die hauptstadt wie hörfunk nochmals
den ein bisschen zum thema osten wir
sehen ja dann nicht nur verluste sondern
verheilen liegen dass die afg sehr viele
direktmandate gewonnen hat
welche schlüsse ziehen sie daraus
heute schon also wird länger
beschäftigen
na gut dass jetzt ansprechen ich jetzt
auch noch mal angesprochen weil das was
mit dieser bundestagswahl auch ziemlich
deutlich geworden ist dass wir ein
gesamtgesellschaftliches problem haben
und wenn wir in den osten schauen dann
haben wir bundesländer ruhe die afg die
wahl gewonnen hat
wir haben tatsächlich auch eine
demografische entwicklung im osten die
sich nach wollen sich auch durch studien
auf demokratische entscheidungen
auswirkt wir haben natürlich das problem
der niedrigen löhne im osten der
sozialen verwerfungen der niedrigen
renten und der anbindung
mit der
[Musik]
demografischen entwicklung der anbindung
des ländlichen raums das wird sich
verschärfen das bedeutet auch dass wir
eine andere gesundheitsversorgung
brauchen dass wir einen anderen
nahverkehr brauchen und und und das
bedeutet eine gesamtdeutsche anstrengung
und da hat ist das natürlich ein
unterschied ob ich wie es die cdu wie es
die westdeutschen parteien tun mit spd
und grünen irgendwie vernachlässigen und
auf den osten gucke und ihn eher
abschreibung oder ob ich positiv darauf
schauen wie die partei die linke den die
potenziale sieht die in zwei
bundesländern regiert und versucht
tatsächlich die soziale frage und die
sozialen verwerfungen ab zu mindern und
wenn wir uns ehrlich machen hat die cdu
in ihren regierungsbeteiligung im osten
immer auf dem rechten
auch nicht geschaut und war blind und
jesus problem sagen zu können wir haben
im osten also ein wirkliches problem mit
rechtsextremismus das gehört an den
beginn von politik aber offenbar ist es
so verfestigt und ich kann ihnen das aus
thüringen sagen mit dem thüringen
monitor der uns seit mindestens 20
jahren zeigt dass der thüringen monitor
erfasst die politischen
einstellungsmuster der thüringerin
einmal im jahr der uns seit knapp 20
jahren sagt dass wir 20 bis 25 prozent
der bevölkerung haben die extrem rechte
einstellungsmuster teilen
und dass die afd
ihnen eine stimme also die möglichkeit
gibt ihre stimme abzugeben zu einer wahl
das ist verheerend und das ist kein auch
da das ist ein komplexes problem das
bedeutet aber dass auf die gesamten
bundespolitik wieder in diese länder
schaut und das hat man es mit sozialen
fragen demokratischen fragen zu tun
ökologischen netz sich an auch mit um
verteilungsfragen
also wenn ich das kurz ergänzen da wir
glauben dass das die zentralen fragen
sind wie sozial ökonomisch wie politisch
sich der osten entwickeln und vielfach
ist die wahl der afg und wir haben ja
gesehen dass sie gerade in sachsen in
extremer stärke aus der wahl
hervorgegangen ist hat auch mit
besonderen verwerfungen zu tun und es
gibt andere beispiele also in meinem
bundesland hat ja auch die kein
direktmandat gewonnen das aber sagt
jetzt nicht dass in mecklenburg
vorpommern das problem ich da wir es ist
eine herausforderung auch für uns und
auch für die anderen parteien dass
gerade in thüringen wo das jan hoet
gelangt na also wo also ein besonders
klar ist das wofür sie stehen dass dann
dort
direktmandate gewonnen werden das ist
schon ein riesen problem und man sieht
zumindest in den wahlkreis von
herrn maßen dass man dann im übrigen das
originalbild denn die ft ist daher
stärker geworden als er das sagt ja auch
was ich meinen beides wäre schlimm weil
es ja stimmen gewesen also dieses
problem ist eine riesenherausforderung
ich würde aber schwer dagegen sprechen
dass jetzt auch den osten zu reduzieren
auch der osten ist differenziert wie im
übrigen der westen und das problem ist
dass wir die herausforderung und zwar an
dem fall sagt jetzt wirklich alle
demokratischen parteien annehmen müssen
die vernachlässigung darf nicht
weitergehen
die nächsten fragen hatte ich auf diese
seite herr kollege genau
was denn eigentlich von watson am was
mir aufgefallen dass beim blick auf die
altersgruppen sie sind zwei jüngeren
wählern sind die zwei unglücklichen
vergleich zu ihrem gesamtergebnis aber
sie haben auch noch sieben bis acht
prozent erreichten verluste erlitten im
vergleich zur vergangenen wahl und
auffällt ja ist fällt auf dass fdp und
grüne über diesen gruppen extrem stark
waren dabei haben sie sich im programm
und dem auftreten sehr stark zum
beispiel das auf youtube man das auf den
parteitagen gesehen aber auch im
wahlprogramm mit diesem sehr
ambitionierten klimazielen warum haben
es trotzdem nicht geschafft bei jungen
menschen zu punkten
wir haben jetzt auch gesehen dass jetzt
bei den erste wählerinnen und wählern
wir im vergleich zum gesamtergebnis
deutlich darüber liegen aber ja wir
haben sagte habe ich auch schon gesagt
haben flächendeckend verloren und zwar
bei allen altersgruppen und zwar in
allen bundesländern und
das geht jetzt darum geht es eben mit
auch das zu analysieren und auszuwerten
warum offensichtlich ja viele junge
menschen bei den grünen sich ihr sehen
oder sogar bei der fdp
das
war ja nun wirklich auch nicht immer so
gewesen in den letzten jahren also
welche entwicklung dazu beiträgt und da
müssen wir überlegen also liegt das an
den inhaltlichen themen liegt das weiß
ich nicht am auftreten wie sprechen wir
junge menschen besser an das sind alles
fragen die wir jetzt analysieren müssen
aber ich glaube es auch gesehen und das
ist ein problem aber
darauf also kleider keine antwort also
welche hätte ich die hätte ich dir heute
dann hätte ich sehr oft versucht vorher
umzusetzen wir haben das versucht also
junge menschen anzusprechen gab ja auch
ein jugend wahlkampf und gerade auch wir
sind ja nicht den klimaschutz bewegung
aktiv wenn junge menschen ansprechen
wollen sondern weil es natürlich für
notwendig halten und dort sind ja auch
also es ist ja auch nicht nur eine junge
bewegung
aber wir haben natürlich auch versucht
gerade ich habe ja auch immer viel das
thema bildung auch im wahlkampf immer
wieder betont
wir haben alle das thema armut und
sozialer gerechtigkeit für studierende
für auszubildende aber offensichtlich
hat es nicht dazu geführt dass wir da
jetzt
zulegen konnten die nächste folge hat
er bat sie hatten heute morgen im
interview gesagt diese tabulos über
inhaltliche strategische und auch
personelle fragen gesprochen werden
können sie das nochmal genauer ausführen
was sie mit personellen fragen zum
beispiel meinen schließen sie sich da
auch vielleicht ein also dieser satz ist
ja wegen der frage nach eventuellen
personal habe ich gesagt tabulos drüber
geredet aber das heißt jetzt nicht dass
ich irgendwie da was konkretes im auge
hätte also das ist nicht der fall
die die reihenfolge war richtig über
politischen die strategischen fragen und
natürlich ist am ende steht auch
personals so ganz klar eine neue
fraktion habe
ich würde sie würde raten dort nicht
hinein zu interpretieren was ich gar
nicht gesagt haben
jetzt
wollen sie denn gerne eine
fraktionsspitze bleiben das werden wir
miteinander bereden und dann wären wir
da entscheidend
nächste frage
kollege
der n tv frau schnell so frau wissler
als die parteispitze vor sechs monaten
übernommen haben sagt die linke bei 8
prozent jetzt wenn sie bei 4,9 wie
wollen sie dann bei der analyse auch
vielleicht persönliche konsequenzen aus
der wahlniederlage ziehen
na ja sie haben sie ja gerade selber
gesagt wir haben ein halbes jahr vor der
bundestagswahl
den parteivorsitz neue übernommen das
war jetzt nicht unsere dass bayerns
geschuldet 102 er wirklich das problem
dass wir wegen corona zweimal den
parteitag verschieben mussten wir hätten
das gerne anders gehabt das konnten wir
wenn man letztes jahr im juni gemacht
hätten oder im oktober werde es sicher
einfacher gewesen sie haben jetzt gesagt
damals waren die umfragen bei 8% ich
glaube das war damals auch nicht alle
umfragen über acht prozent waren weil
ich mich damals bin ich nämlich schon
mal gefragt worden warum wir in den
umfragen so rum dümpeln als wir hatten
dann auch mal eine umfrage mit 8 prozent
aber wir haben zwei wochen nach der wahl
hat werder zwei landtagswahlen ja wohl
wirklich das gute in einem ein land das
auf niedrigem niveau ein bisschen
hochgegangen dem anderen haben wir
verloren also von daher würde ich sagen
die situation war damals schwierig und
wir haben die sagte er sehr kurz da hat
es ja vor der bundestagswahl den
parteivorsitz übernommen und natürlich
auch viele prozesse schon
angelaufen waren es waren sehr
forderndes und sehr anstrengendes halbes
jahr jetzt einfach so eine
bundestagswahl als neu gewählte
vorsitzende vorzubereiten natürlich
hätten wir auch einfach kaum
möglichkeiten jetzt sowohl in die partei
wirklich mal den rhein zu hören dann kam
die ganze kohle situation dazu also ich
meine der neugewählte parteivorstand
trifft sich jetzt am wochenende zum
ersten mal im präsident zum ersten mal
war das vorher einfach nicht gegenwehr
musste ein parteitag vorbereiten und da
würde ich sagen haben wir jetzt ein paar
sachen also wir haben ja eine hohe
zustimmung zum wahlprogramm zb gehabt
wir haben die spitzenkandidatur frage
sehr einvernehmlich in der partei gelöst
also von daher
ich glaube ich dass das einfach auch das
auch wirklich objektiv ungünstige
bedingungen waren und jetzt diskutieren
wir am samstag und sonntag mit dem
parteivorstand darüber welche
schlussfolgerungen wir jetzt ziehen und
also
wir sind die bundesvorsitzende sind die
parteivorsitzende unsere partei und
natürlich tragen wir die verantwortung
dafür und deswegen sagen wir wir gehen
in einem gemeinsamen prozess wir sind
aber auch bereit weiter diese partei
durch diesen prozess zu führen und ich
glaube das schlechteste was wir jetzt
machen können uns in dieser situation
vom acker zu machen und zu sagen jetzt
macht mal wir haben hier ein halbes jahr
gearbeitet war offenbar zumindest was
das bundestagswahl ergebnis
angeht schwierig
aber schon wissen hat ja gesagt wir
haben uns sofort in die wellen geworfen
da haben wir auch mal den ein oder
anderen persönlichen fehler gemacht er
einfach passiert aber nochmal die das
wahlergebnis ist ein gebilde aus ganz
ganz vielen puzzleteilen und darum geht
es und es geht für uns darum dass wir
die verantwortung weiter tragen und
tatsächlich auf die partei die linke in
diesem prozess nicht allein lassen
ich befürchte dass die ursachen einfach
tiefer liegen er ist dass man es einfach
durch
personalentscheidung haben würden wir
sofort gehen und wege und mit 10 ich
glaube wirklich werden wenn man sich die
ja auch die idee langfristig die
wahlergebnisse anschaut in den letzten
jahren ja dann sieht man einfach dass
wir an vielen orten strukturellen
problemen haben im westen wo wir einfach
viele weiße flecken haben und einfach
nie strukturen aufbauen konnten und im
osten wo es einfach wirklich einfach was
weggebrochen ist also von daher glaube
ich dass es
so einfach wäre jetzt einfach zu sagen
mit personal oder so verändert sich
sondern die ursachen liegen tiefer und
ansonsten gilt wir gewinnen wahlen
zusammen und wir verlieren zusammen wir
sind eine partei und deswegen tragen wir
auch gemeinsam dafür verantwortung
alle gemeinsam ist den treffer jaja
nehmen dürfe redaktions netzwerk
deutschland sie haben die meisten
stimmen an die spd verloren ich glaube
600.000 danach folgen die grünen läuft
die linke gefahr aufgesogen zu werden
ist noch platz für
sozialdemokratie und linke
also ich sehe diese gefahr real nicht
wir haben leider diese wähler bewegung
gehabt und sie haben mit der frage
durchsetzungs kompetenz zu tun jeder
wusste dass die grünen in der nächsten
regierung sein werden
und ich will auch nicht verhehlen dass
natürlich diese ganze geschichte mit tri
allen dingen natürlich sehr in die
karten gespielt hat das war dann eine
positionierung wo drei parteien in
besonderer weise im fokus waren aber sie
haben richtig beschrieben wenn wir
zweimal also wenn die elf prozent
gewinnen und wie er über 4% verlieren
dann ist das für uns eine
herausforderung und geht es auch darum
das kenntlich zu machen aber wenn die
antwort jetzt wäre deutschland wird gut
werden es keine linke mehr gäbe
dann könnte man darüber nachdenken dass
teile ich aber ausdrücklich nicht gerade
angesichts der herausforderung und
gerade
wenn im nächsten bundestag wirklich eine
soziale opposition gebraucht wird und da
wird man jetzt mal losgelöst von der
konstellation ich glaube dass es noch
sehr sehr offen willst du noch einige
zeit
ins land gehen wird aber in jedem fall
wird man ein soziales gewissen der
deutschen bundestag brauchen das ist
meine feste überzeugung und deswegen ist
die herausforderung für uns alle groß
das ist so gerade nach dem gestrigen
haben aber es ist eben auch immer eine
chance und als jemand der paar tage
dabei ist weiß ich das teil dann am
stärksten waren die herausforderung am
größten waren das ist übrigens auch eine
erkenntnis der letzten vier jahre wir
waren viel zu lange in dieser sicheren
position weil wir haben ja 87 prozent
das ist nicht gut für eine partei weil
zu viele haben in der zeit glaubt
spielen zu können das zählen glaube ich
die drei hier vorne sitzenden nicht dazu
ja ich sehe diese gefahr das aufgesogen
werden dass ich da mal so wenn ich jetzt
olaf scholz zu zuhören würde ich schon
sagen da ist ja noch deutlich platz
links von ihm also mit setzt sich so
auch wenn die spd jetzt einen wahlkampf
gemacht hat er vielleicht sehr stark auf
die sozialen themen gesetzt hat da ist
ja schon noch eine ganze menge platz
links davon den wir aber fühlen müssen
und das haben wir nicht geschafft bei
dieser wahl oder völlig unzureichend
geschafft aber
ich denke gerade wenn man sich auch die
politik der großen koalition anschaut
dann sehen wir ja dass da viele probleme
natürlich überhaupt erst geschaffen
wurden und entstanden sind und das ist
bitter und das tut mir auch weh dass wir
diesen ja diesen platz links davon nicht
so fühlen konnten wie es notwendig
gewesen wäre
wir müssen langsam zum ende kommen ich
habe noch viele wortmeldungen wir
versuchen uns zu schaffen mit kurzen
fragen kurzen antworten halb problem
wer sie haben gibt viele strukturelle
probleme geräte noch mal zu fehlern im
wahlkampf event ja die dass die rote
socken kampagne der union macht landen
die hat ja letztlich funktioniert haben
sie der falsch oder nicht ausreichend
darauf reagiert
ich will es noch mal deutlich sagen
glaube dass die fehler nicht im
wahlkampf gelegen haben auf jeden fall
nicht in der positionierung die wir
vorgenommen haben sowohl inhaltlich
personell als auch strategisch dagegen
wie eine rote-socken-kampagne da können
wir nichts machen und hat die csu
besonderer weise nach vorne gestellt
ich würde nur wiedersprechen denjenigen
die sagen ja das nutzen euch ja das ist
falsch weil es ist schon so dass viele
menschen sagen naja die wären damit euch
gar nicht usw und das hat ja auch combe
scholz hat dass er relativ deutlich
gemacht hat jedes mal irgendwie zwar nie
ausgeschlossen aber schon gesagt mit
denen will ich nicht und das ist
natürlich ein problem ist so ganz klar
aber ich teile da die sicht von susanne
und janine dass es nicht die letzten
wochen waren die haben uns zwar jetzt
auch die 4,9 gebracht aber da gibt es
andere ursachen die tiefer liegen
vielleicht daran erinnern dass es hervor
ich glaube vor sechs oder acht wochen
gab es eine umfrage die mich sehr
überrascht hatte oder rot-rot-grün die
beliebteste koalition gewesen sei also
zwar schwachen wert 37 prozent aber
damals war die ampel und rot-rot-grün
beide gleich bei 37 prozent als
beliebteste konstellation als jetzt mal
vorausgesetzt dass die umfrage jetzt
substanz hatte er hat mich das
überrascht und das hat sich aber gedreht
in den wahlkampf das muss man wirklich
deutlich sagen also das später war er
dann auf einmal die große koalition noch
beliebter und das ist das eine
vielleicht wirklich diese linksrutsch
rote-socken-kampagne aber der ich glaube
das war's eben auch nicht allein oder
die einzigen die wirklich mehr
ausgestrahlt haben dass man sowas gut
fände und dafür zur verfügung stehen
waren ja nur wir also das von also von
der spd gab es jetzt er hat signale
immer richtung fdp und auch von den
grünen richtung fdp als richtung uns
deswegen haben glaube ich viele diese
konstellation nicht mehr als so
wahrscheinlich wahrgenommen oder eben
auch wenn sie halt auch immer wieder
gesagt wird und die steht im abseits und
ihr könnt das geht nicht ich will damit
nur sagen dass eigentlich diese
startposition gar nicht so schlecht war
so schon leute gehabt wie gesagt haben
das wäre auch noch optionen und das hat
sie über den wahlkampf in der tat
gedreht und das hat uns nicht geholfen
würde ich auch sagen das stammt von
orders fragt wie viel zeit nehmen sich
für die analyse der wahlergebnisse
missbraucht dann habe ich noch tun und
herren reitschuster co eine frage an
frau friesland freien nicht welt so an
sie haben von den prozess gesprochen
welche rolle spielt da ein mögliches
neues parteiprogramm das erfurter
programm ist schon zehn jahre alten
zwischen und mit kurzen frage an herrn
barth wird der fraktionsvorstand der
neue vor der klausur des parteivorstands
zum wochenende gewählt hatten
also wir beginnen jetzt in den prozess
einzusteigen und natürlich schauen wir
uns alle möglichkeiten an wie wir auch
mit unserer mitgliedschaft
neu definieren können beziehungsweise
definieren können wo wir uns in dieser
gesellschaft sehen und was wir wollen
und da gehört eine mögliche debatte um
ein neues parteiprogramm so wenig
wahlprogramm seiner partei programm
natürlich dazu als option das werden wir
aber natürlich mit dem parteivorstand
besprechen das eine ein parteiprogramm
prozess immer eine sehr intensive
auseinandersetzung mit gesellschaft und
partei an sich es ist auch klar aber es
ist ein weg
neuer
inhaltliche gemeinsamkeiten auf den weg
zu bringen
die fraktion wird sich morgen das erste
mal treffen die 39 abgeordneten und da
werden wir dazu auch eine entscheidung
treffen
und der letzte fragesteller
im verfassungsschutzbericht werden vier
strukturen der linken als extremistisch
geführt glauben sie dass diese
extremisten in ihrer partei nicht wähler
abgeschreckt haben und wie wollen sie
mit diesen extremisten in ihrer partei
umgehen danke also ehrlich gesagt ich
antworte darauf sehr gern weil ich
möchte auch verweisen dass derjenige der
am häufigsten in
verfassungsschutzberichten stand ich bin
wie viele jahre war ich immer also eine
besondere verankerung in diesem jetzt
nicht mehr und bis
2014 war auch ich einer derjenigen die
vom verfassungsschutz beobachtet worden
sind von maaßen und erst als ich dann in
des überwachungsgremiums des bundestages
der die geheimdienste über da welches
geheimdienst überwacht wurde das
eingestellt und durch unsere klagen ich
finde das ehrlich gesagt eine
unverschämtheit dass das überhaupt
stattfindet und wir werden weiterhin mit
aller konsequenz dagegen kämpfen dass
die linke überhaupt im
verfassungsschutzbericht auftauen findet
das schräg und warum ist es die position
ganz klar was extremismus betrifft wenn
ich jetzt ihre wortwahl aufnehme hat bei
uns keinen platz punkt
dann sind wir am ende eine zusatzfrage
nachfolgender also wenn sie das jetzt
durch lesen weswegen diese strukturen
als extremistisch eingestuft werden dann
ist das ziemlich heftig andere
gesellschaftsordnung und dergleichen
sich der verfassungsschutz gewaltige
oder haben sie darm problemen
verfassungsschutz wird sich gewaltig
eine andere gesellschaft also das sag
ich auch hier in der
bundespressekonferenz unser
programmatisches ziel ist der
demokratische sozialismus wer das als
extremistisch einschätzt der kann das
tun steht im spd programm auch also ich
glaube dass hier leider ein stückweit
instrumentalisiert wird wir haben das
wirklich auf dem klageweg er mehrfach
überprüfen lassen und gewonnen weil
abgeordnete der der damalige abgeordnete
bodo ramelow war noch in der überwachung
der wahl schon ministerpräsident da
sehen immer was für ein irrsinn dort
veranstaltet wird